It can be a challenge to neatly join
seams, especially when you're working in
stitch patterns.
For this slip stitch sample.
I joined the seam on the machine.
It looks okay a whole lot better than
if I had tried to seam this by hand.
All I did was rehang each side seam edge
back on the needles with the public or the
right sides facing each other.
Knit one row, then hand knit one loose row
and bind off stitch through stitch.
Okay.
It looks okay, but what about adding
a decorative touch to this seam?
Hang the first edge with
the public side facing you.
Then e-Wrap loosely, cast
on over those needles.
Then hang the other edge, making a
sandwich with the right sides of the work,
facing each other.
Then bind off loosely.
Even better.
Use a double strand of
yarn for the e-Wrap.
Beautiful.
How about using this technique
for a show off shoulder seam!
Perfect for all over patterns
and especially for fair isle.